[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
s'arrête la chronique la plus courte
sortie aux couleurs de l'émission c'est
très beau et aujourd'hui celle indique
qu'il vient ça va le spécialiste images
et ils sont celles indique parce qu'on a
c'est un lot semaine dernière un pilote
alors c'est un essai pour voir voilà
comment marchent les missions même si ça
fait 12 ans pour la fée ou encore
vous dire un petit peu le niveau de
l'équipe
pilate avions dit bonjour et tout comme
si c'était vraiment une vraie mission
sera comme ça on reprend tout depuis le
début quoi et donc il était là il va
montrer digne des images du pilote parce
que les autres on se lâche encore plus
voilà un c'est vrai c'est dommage
qu'elle ait pas été diffusée cette
émission a réclamé des téléspectateurs
vont découvrir ça dans un instant parce
que je vais vous raconter en fait toute
l'histoire du pilat du début jusqu'à la
vie raconte la nuit oui la casse toi c
mais vous allez voir
comme un castor non je te plaît toutes
les nouvelles rubriques toutes les
nouvelles séquences mais d'abord cyril
ce que je suis l'indiquent donc je sais
tout je vois tout je dénonce tout ce qui
se passe pendant les offres pendant les
magnétos pendant les pubs et c'est le
retour de la séquence star du paf cyril
c'est quoi ces 50 go l'insight tpp
tout c'est le retour de sakho et on
commence tout de suite avec le petit
nouveau dans le lévy visiblement
géraldine il leur vie devant vous et que
même titre qu'elle sonne le coup qui
nous
[Musique]
cette saison une chose est sûre on va
garder le sens des priorités on adopte
un lajaunie là je dois faire un p 250
mais j'ai btp mais je crois que j'ai
annulé mais
tbl peu demandons des pêcheurs il a
enfin sa statue au musée grévin comme
moi on ne me sentais pas trop départ à
la galerie en rigolant
je sens je sens que ma galerie crois que
ma galerie l'atelier cadart
[Musique]
pour moi
m
avec cyril c'est qu'il n'ait jamais
hypocrite
car il n'est pas le seul hypocrite dans
l'équipe regarde pernikoff n'est pas mal
tu là aussi
super bien et vous quittez la maison qui
revient dtp mp vous êtes célibataire
venez vite il ya un chroniqueur rien à
sauver
cette nouvelle saison tpp marquée par le
retour de matthieu delormeau toujours
aussi humble celui-ci
démission
[Rires]
c'était encore cyril cet honneur est
bonne 25 secondes
michel mercier
chez twitter
enfin
car est pas de rigoler leurs troupes
pour tuer de cyril authentique naturel
c'est comme ça compte un blu ray un
cadeau aux élections de pour toi il est
rappelé quelque chose un instant je peux
son micro qu'est ce qui se passe il va
sortir ce boom
[Rires]
alors je me dis restez pour sa chronique
parce que iris qui à bord ils risquent
des échauffourées
quand vous allez voir le pilote dans un
instant mais d'abord je fais dure un peu
le suspense que cette saison où vous
l'avez vu elle est marquée par le retour
de matthieu delormeau et mature on le
connaît on les aime bien mais il aime
bien peu tout ce qui brille du coup pour
l'accueillir ce droit je suis sûr que
vous allez voir dans un instant regardez
comment les chroniqueurs l'accueil ils
ont voulu pas pour fêter son retour le
piéger qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont
fait croire à mathieu que guillaume
genton et est devenu millionnaire grâce
à la crypto monnaie regardez bien la
l'accident c'est bien la raison de
mathieu quand il a appris que guillaume
avait touché le jackpot ben 10 il a plus
envie de le connaître regarder
[Musique]
ce sens va mais je devais les endives
200 femmes
vision comment vont réagir matthieu
delormeau
toujours maison
[Musique]
je me présente et g
bien
et
j'aime pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est une pente de la gym aller mais qui
est la meilleur travail il fallait me
présenter qu'est ce qu'il faut ici
extraordinaire ah mais j'ai cru messages
et des fringues de marque c'est pour ça
qu'on est content de vous retrouver
aussi vous êtes extrême n'est pas
changer comme ça qu'on vous aime donc
j'ai traversés
c'était magnifique lob les soumet et lui
alors lui il est à fond dans le
personnage lui parce que le club a en
fait qu'il n'y croyait vraiment que face
au but
il est rentré chez lui le soir et avait
écouté j'ai gagné des sauces
[Rires]
mais j'en suis désolé mais je reconnais
que j'ai déjà raconté à dix autres
producteurs dans paris le lendemain tu
es ce bâtard de gens
donc ça va te revenir un peu
parlé de cette affaire
c'est dans voici après le match
a très bien ça très drôle cyril chose
promise chose due on va passer aux
pilotes de tpm avec toutes les images
que vous à la maison vous n'avez pas vu
à la télé c'est le principe du pilote et
c'est devenu un classique chaque année
il ya un problème au tout début du
pilote c'est là mais à la lumière
exactement eh bien regardez bien
l'arrivée de cyril sur le plateau ce
n'est pas bavarde l'animateur ce n'est
pas baba le producteur c'est baba le
directeur artistique d'avoir ça file
droit
[Musique]
n'oubliez pas que c'est très très sombre
mais tout ça et même rien ovale
je vais vous dire je vous laisse encore
deux choses sinon je suis en régie
à les mecs ça c'est pas mal c'est trop
beau à la wii ou pas pourrait
franchement
ça fait c'est ça
très bon le sénateur est franchement
pour l'audience que ça fait chier
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je dénonce tout est oui bon maintenant
la lumière il faut que le point de lui
mais rien qu'on marque simulia moment un
jour
donné un peu de jeu mais c'est vrai quoi
on est content de ce que vous dites
[Rires]
bond de ce que
c'était ma péniche on accourt j'arrête
pas de kent
non mais quand j'ai lancé cyril féraud
sur france 3
là nicolas pernikoff le problème de
l'allumer réglé on peut passer aux
pilotes et cyril arrive sur le plateau
baba faut savoir que ça fait deux mois
qu'il n'a pas mis les pieds ici du coup
les chroniqueurs sont censés lui avoir
un peu manqué mais c'est baba regardez
bien c'est le retour de cyril à la mort
de pas trop
quel plaisir de voir comme cheikh tu vas
faire quel pilote
mes orchidées elle pousse ans au moins
100 magnifique salle agenaise et une
charrette non mais ça va chez les
voisins et chez tout le monde
le 6 à 7 démarre à comme son nom
l'indiqué à 18h05 la semaine prochaine
c'est benjamin castaldi d'accord alors
s'ils ouvrent les yeux et
mal joué
par extension sur les bouts je voudrais
bien
guillaume sera certainement au
successeur à la tête deux fois à la tête
des tpe dans combien de temps ses 30 ans
il faut que vous sachiez c'est qu'entre
géraldine maillet et raymonde hazan de
ce côté là il ya le qi de toute
l'histoire de l'émission
et dessins aussi pour vous il colle pas
du gospel à peine de faire si
on peut avoir une bonne bavette coup
comme une [ __ ] 1
[Applaudissements]
ce qui n'est pas volé en éclats
dix pilotes dit au site est donc de
nouveaux chroniqueurs et deux nouvelles
chroniqueuses mais regardez bien on va
pas se mentir cyril elles sont pas
toutes logées à la même enseigne fois
d'ailleurs à nîmes un nouveau jeu c'est
chacun son tour qui marche plutôt bien
gros débris
pas de regarder parce que je t'emmènerai
raison
[Rires]
eh bien monsieur pernikoff d'imaginer
qu'il est gay qu'une potion pour vous
permettre de faire revenir votre ex drac
roche en ce moment la raison line up de
vaincre us
et vous parlez
comme à côté 9 sillonna des audiences
vous dansez vous un peu alors comme un
valet voulait me faire des concerts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors qu'elle y faire des jo tu peux
considérer que c'est bon
[Rires]
vous savez vous le savez vous qui me
suivait depuis des années on est des
missions bien sûr médias actualité dense
donc si c'est bon voilà non mais tout
était très érotique d'ailleurs sarah
sera avec nous à partir la semaine
prochaine puisqu'elle voit un sujet
toutes les semaines et fiona aussi
d'être nouvelle il est aidé en plus
elles sont géniales on me tapait les
trois vraiment fiona exceptionnelle de
fer et une mallette danse et on n'en
parle même pas bien entendu mais à lille
miss météo sur m6 voilà lazare qu'elle
soit belle en plus
ont par contre c'est par hasard que vous
soyez
banon match dit pas que des conneries
elle est miss météo sur m6 mais pour
l'instant elle est en contrat avec m6 va
donc à la fedama venir s'amuser avec
nous mais voilà on sait jamais on pourra
peut-être s'arranger voilà avec nos amis
des musées ce qu'on aime beaucoup vous
le savez c'est dans la vue la lumière on
l'a vu les chroniqueurs mais vous avez
aussi tester des happenings enfin à
rester c'est vite dit il a voulu faire
une canard avec son meilleur ami jan
mais comment vous dire que c'est un
happening que vous ne verrez jamais où
il touchera mon poste il a juste voulu
voir son meilleur pote ça s'appelle
lionel pepsi le pilote
juste pour bas histoire tout le look et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
père noël c'est vrai qu'il a fait des
efforts yann où il a mis les crampons le
chante la perruque mais siri vous n'avez
pas dû faire ça on a quand même le faire
ce jeu
est tout de suite ce jeu on fait pas les
questions les ré ouvert c'est pas la
peine franchement je pense qu'on va on
va c'est pas la peine d'en bref je
t'emmerde
c'est pas la peine il était sur pilotis
licenciés cyril dans ce pilote on a
découvert une chose c'est votre
complicité avec guillaume j'entends avec
qui vous avez parties une partie de
l'été non une relation qui est faite
d'amitié ouais de sexe et d'argent non
[Rires]
j'y crois
encore au sec
regardez on a assisté à la naissance de
quelque chose pour ce pilote
guillaume avec qui j'ai passé des
soirées mémoire le web le grand maman à
dragon on est autant été remis au temps
maintenant on est frères c'est vrai
alors carrément à et je n'ai vu tout nu
[Applaudissements]
société magiciens ils n'auraient pas
besoin de maquettes
[Rires]
donnez moi mais à quelle occasion
bonjour la cour s'est baigné nu dans la
piscine c'est mieux c'est il s'est
baigné nu et moi je me tenais à la barre
ils étaient pas venus pour ça au départ
est venu pour travailler
donc essayé
[Applaudissements]
et de légumes payet n'est pas que je
parte un aveu je descends
vous aussi cyril vous êtes dévoile un
guillaume genton indices margaritas
latham et shui vous êtes un peu confié à
moi sur vos origines j'ai appris que
vous étiez italien et
son vrai nom n'est pas cyril sont
vraiment c'est paulo
[Rires]
l'histoire est d'amender l'accord je
m'érige ne t'interdit de m'appeler cyril
je m'appelle pas où on est à la plage je
me retournais paulo
alors il ya des métiers beaucoup dame
était certes mais c'est avant tout du
business dirige pas si on vous a dit que
guillaume genton était actionnaire du ce
nouvel habillage ah oui c'est toi qui
leur revient j'avais à coeur de bien
dans l'habillage
[Applaudissements]
et font de l'oseille partout
ah oui toujours là se séparer j'aime
beaucoup l'habillage s'attirer de mieux
dans les mineures
l'eau
ce dont je dois dans les rails et un
truc à lui c'est parce que le tube de
l'année dans cette émission c'est les
fdp ouais les flingueurs lagarde ouest
et y en aura tout à l'heure en temps et
on inverse d un show exceptionnel entre
fabrice di vizio et j'en mets cia
regardez c'est complètement ouf on
comprend pourquoi les séquenceurs
dans l'institut apollon
partie naufrageurs dit pas
ces gens messia toujours aussi élégant
vraiment on veut travailler toujours à
la mode oui bah vous aussi apparemment
[Rires]
j'ai failli venir en uniforme d'air
france pourquoi asséné me faut plusieurs
pilotes
[Applaudissements]
tous les samedis pendant tout l'été les
pâtisseries à tout l'été vous gouverner
pendant que j'étais données
scientifiques vous lisez gunner ce n'est
pas
ce qui se passe c'est que quand tu poses
des questions quand tu contestes au
contenu critique ensuite on coupe le
sifflet voilà ce qui se passe et on le
fait qu'on n'entende pas je le regrette
tout cas moi j'aurais dit c'est enfin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais je parle comme
papa de liberté j'accepte de me casser
la voix sans peine cassé
[Applaudissements]